Nicholas B and to some extent Matt Welsh
their version of reason was sex drugs
and rock and roll mine is more like sex
drugs and robots I'm Virginia postural I
was the editor of Reason magazine in
1990s and tonight we're speaking with
Katherine mango ward reason magazine's
newest editor in about 10 or 15 minutes
we'll take some questions from those of
you who are watching live on Facebook
but let's start out with so you're the
editor of the print magazine and back in
back in my day when I became editor that
was the only reason magazine and today
of course reason has a huge web presence
2.5 million visitors and compared to
this still holding steady at 50,000
subscribers to the print magazine what
do you see as the role of a print
magazine of any kind and specifically
this one in the digital age so as
someone who reads virtually nothing on
dead tree I'm actually in kind of a
weird position that I'm you know editing
a magazine every month I mean I think
you know for for us you know
increasingly we just look to make the
best content that we can make and then
we put it wherever it makes sense so you
know the magazine is still a place to
house really big juicy long-form
features and I think people do like to
read them in that form I mean I I know
that when I'm reading online I tend to
maybe trail away before I get to the end
of the article I think having the
physical magazine serves that it's sort
of a I was gonna say a nag but maybe
that's not you know it's not a visual
reminder that you should finish that
story because there's probably good
stuff at the end and I think it's a
little bit more of a lasting product I
mean you know I would like to think when
you look through the archives of Reason
magazine you can sort of get a sense of
okay well this is what Virginia Vostro
was up to in the 90s this is what Nick
Gillespie was up to this is Matt Welsh
and hopefully people will have a sense
of the kind of evolution of reason as as
my editorship occurs and you became
editor officially what July first like
five minutes ago yeah so my my first
issue
is out and I was the managing editor
before that so my my dirty little paws
are all over some Matt Welsh issues as
well but the the official first issue
with my name at the top of the mat set
is the October issue which yes it's
August and yes the October issue just
came out because print is a weird place
I like to think that we live in the
future in print like I'm already the
election is over for me so I should
probably be really jealous of me
actually and and speaking of the future
of the print issues you have some
changes coming up starting with what the
January issue yes we're burning the
printing presses to the ground and
starting over no we are we're
redesigning the issue the magazine so
for now the changes will just be the
print magazine and it will be sometime
in early 2017 that you'll be seeing the
the new issue come out a couple of
reasons for that one it's been a long
time since we redesigned the last
redesign was in 2001 and while I'm sure
that it was cutting edge in 2001
you know that's that's a good long time
ago now we also have a new art director
Joanna andresen who is super talented
she's based in Brooklyn and you know
she's eager to bring her stanton I think
we're doing the redesign in-house which
is something the last redesign we
shopped out it's easier to do that now I
mean the the tools that are available
are better and also it's just something
that Joanna has experience in she was
the founding graphic designer for the
probably the only Swedish libertarian
magazine which was called which is
called neo and so this is something that
she's done before right now we're still
doing a little bit too much of
publishing six-week-old news on dead
tree and shoving any people's mailboxes
and I think that doesn't really make
sense anymore when so many of our print
readers also read online so in addition
to a new look what can readers look
forward to with the debut of the most
important thing they can look forward to
is a return of Virginia postural to our
pages that's a columnist
which it's actually part of like a
decade-long scheme by me to to basically
I have like sheryl sandberg to virginia
for years like i keep calling her being
like will you be my mentor and she's
like who are you again
you never asked me to know and i would
never use those words because that's
horrible but anyway we but we believe
that recent editor should be raised by
wolves we out meant that's right that's
right and i think that's an accurate
description if you replace wolves with
Nick Gillespie that's right so I column
by you we're gonna have Deidre McCluskey
in our pages as well we're gonna have a
sort of a lifestyle advice type column
which will be shared by Lenore scan
Daisy who's our free-range mom and also
Jerry to Chile whose inaugural column I
think is gonna be about the importance
of teaching your children to shoot
rattlesnakes so so it's gonna be kid or
yes it's gonna it won't always be kid
oriented but but those are sort of two
writers that we're going to bring in and
we're gonna kind of move to more column
length stuff in the front stuff that has
a little bit more staying power also
more visual so for those of you who go
to the back of the magazine and look for
the artifact which is that little object
with the blurb we're gonna be doing more
of that in the front of the book we're
also instituting a centerfold so if
anyone has you know playboy stopped
publishing nudes so we're gonna step up
and do our part with that tradition they
will not actually be nude just for the
record but we are going to feature a
kind of an interview at a big photo of
somebody in our universe who will it
fold out it will not fill that but it
will be so so talking about the
lifestyle
column gives me a little segue to what I
think of as the Brian lamb portion of
our interview because Brian lamb well he
when he does book notes he'll be asking
you about what you said on page 259 and
then he says where'd you grow up
are you gonna later ask me to define
very basic words like that's another I
grew up inside the beltway in Washington
DC so I am I'm essentially a DC lifer
and my parents were good government
liberals and I and what I do they they
my mom works in public health and my dad
was an architect and I read I rant when
I was 15 and that was probably the
beginning of end the gateway drug and
and and are you married single I am my
husband and I live in Dupont Circle
downtown about three blocks from the
reason office because I'm incredibly
lazy and we have two kids and how old
are they they are five and two girls
boys the eldest is a girl in the
youngest is a boy and I don't see how
you do that because I think being edit
reason requires no children overlapping
skill set to manage freelance writers
and where where did you go to school so
I went to TC Williams High School in
Alexandria which is for anyone ever saw
the movie Remember the Titans that is
the school that produced me for a better
force and then Yale is an undergrad
where I majored in political science and
philosophy and edited the Yale Free
Press which is not the real paper that
you that would be the Yale Daily oh and
and why politics and philosophy so like
I say I read Iran when I was fifteen but
I just kind of was like I'm an
Objectivist I'm better than everyone and
I think I was probably super horrible to
be around that summer but worked my way
through all of Iran's writings I went to
a sort of perfectly decent school but
I've never been exposed at all to ethics
or really philosophy of any kind or
economics so if you can imagine that
like basically I I was like this lady is
on to some amazing stuff you guys like
she has these theories about how the
world works
and I I kind of made it all the way
through high school and then I got to
college and and actually it's quite
clever at Yale there's a there's a front
that's called the objective a study
group at Yale but it's all ex
Objectivist and they bring you in and
then they say oh no what you what you
really probably are is a libertarian
who's interested in philosophy have you
read and then they like give you a big
stack of books other thinkers and as was
true in my case you're like oh my god
they're right you know I actually am a
libertarian who's interested in
philosophy and not strictly speaking an
Objectivist although I still feel fondly
toward my Mayan right so what other
writers have influenced you either back
then or more recently so back then I
kind of worked my way through the Canon
you know libertarian Canon aided and
abetted by like the the college
libertarian industrial complex right so
like you know they have to do for you
main studies and the collegiate Network
and a whole bunch of other groups when
they notice somebody out there who might
agree with them they kind of send you
off to conferences and it's all very
nice these days I would actually say the
the books that most influenced me or
science fiction you know Ramez naam who
is a recommendation from reasons science
correspondent Ron Bailey who writes sort
of incredibly evocative books one of the
best ones is it's called Nexus and in it
there's this description of how
prohibition will fail when we're trying
to prohibit mind-altering computer code
right and it's like that's not something
that's like okay we are gonna need to
cover that issue and reason today but
I'd like to think we're gonna need to
cover that issue in reason before my
tenure as editor so that's kind of where
I'm I guess I'm looking to find new
ideas or like you know something that's
cutting edge so being an editor being a
writer are two different things and I
one of the things used to amuse me when
I was editor was that people thought
that this you know 60 hour week that I
was working was devoted to writing one
editorial a month but so there are ideas
that you like to write about as a writer
and their ideas you like to write about
I'd like to have written about by other
people and I'd like to talk about both
of those you mentioned science fiction
you're obviously very
interested in technology in the future
and I believe in this new redesign
you're gonna do a column right yeah on
this yes I mean there will be an editors
column it will each of the cons have a
sort of topic heading and mine might be
something like futurism
and so what draws you to those issues so
I think a lot of libertarians are very
pessimistic like the world is collapsing
around our ears and like
authoritarianism is upon us but there's
this sort of countervailing thread of
almost like manic optimism that's like
we're gonna have a colony on Mars in
five minutes and I'm just like totally
on that side of the equation like I just
think like I just look around me and see
good news everywhere and the easiest way
to convey that sense of optimism is to
say you know here's the technology
that's coming in in you know a year or
two years or ten years but also just a
friendly reminder that you have
basically impossible technologies and
amenities in your life already and if
you are tempted by a decline in era t'v
you should fight it because the reality
is far from that and aside from your own
work things that you might write what do
you want to see more of in the magazine
either topics or types of articles so
one thing that I've kind of I guess
stumbled into is managing editor and
hope to do more of as editor-in-chief is
to look a little bit outside the borders
of the United States reason historically
has had international coverage but it's
been kind of spotty and it's come and
gone over the years we have you know a
great piece a couple issues ago about
coffee growing coffee in Haiti and how
the coffee trees in Haiti are very
poorly tended because of the incentives
that are created by the kind of foreign
aid machine you know it's not really a
lesson that's like applicable to the
United States it's just a thing I
thought was cool and it's a former
Reason intern who wrote it we also have
Jim Epstein our one of our video
producers went to Brazil recently and
covered this amazing libertarian
Riven uprising that unseated a head of
state there and I think that's something
that reason should obviously be covering
and it's sort of flown below the radar
in a lot of ways these are people who
are holding up signs like that have
Mises face on them they're they're like
shouting like more privatization in the
streets like million people shouting for
privatization in the streets which I
don't know about you guys but like when
I wake up in the middle of the night
like that's what I'm dreaming about
so the Haiti article is actually in the
new issue yeah this is this shows how
editors get I don't know about it didn't
have no idea what run but it is
especially it's even more extreme if you
live in Southern California where camp
over what anyway so my father called me
this morning
hello and my father almost never calls
me usually I call him at and I'm like
I'm on deadline what is and and he had
gotten a new issue of reason that
doesn't all my phone calls and and he
had read your lead editorial Trump
versus Clinton versus everything good
where you where you quote the future and
its enemies my book that's why daddy was
it doesn't care about your argument he
only cares about his little sign says
but and and a lot of this is about the
permission what sometimes called the
permissionless economy asking you start
over and you don't ask permission you
try to build and I wanted you to talk
about I'm sort of skeptical I know that
this works sometime but part of the
reason I wrote the future and its
enemies was that I felt like there are
genuine threats there are enemies people
things can be closed down but you're
pretty optimistic yeah I mean it's
potentially a character flaw I'm open to
that interpretation
I mean I think yes the future has
enemies and I think goober is actually a
great example and I get into it I sort
of hint at it in my head note but um
they're this incredible model of
permissionless innovation they're also a
model of how quickly you go from being
an upstart to a red seeker
right I mean uber is in New York in
particular has already given into a
bunch of pressure from from the state
and from the city of New York they've
acted to push through rules and
regulations and guidelines that will
probably hedge out their competitors so
the evolution can be so you can be the
hero in the villain of the same story
and I think you know I must coos also
mentioned there it can be a
controversial figure among libertarians
for the same reasons he's you know has
many professed free-market principles
dudes start at a rocky company because
screwed NASA and at the same time he's
no NASA is now a customer and there are
people of mixed feelings about that I do
not have mixed feelings about that by
the way and think he's kind of a hero
but I guess I just think it's the
relative rates of growth and change that
are the main thing I just think at least
in my memory the spectacular growth of
the future is is not sufficiently
[ __ ] by its anomie used to make me
alarmed to the extent that I think
you're the sort of one argument is that
it channel's the regular the nature of
regulations that channels innovation in
certain ways so we have a tremendous
amount of regulation in the world I mean
a tremendous amount of innovation in the
world of bits because it's lightly
regulated we have much less innovation
at least visible innovation in the world
of atoms because there are many more
video players it's more it's more
explicitly regulated and they're just
also many more ways to stop things and
whether you're talking about material
science or whether you're talking about
building houses or whatever it or uber
and one of the interesting things about
these gig economy things businesses is
that they use the world of bits but
they're really in the world of atoms
there and so I wonder if there is I
don't know there's hope there there
there is or or is it that we just kind
of have to take what we can get I mean I
think what we can get is pretty good
still so that's kind of my bottom line
we'll say I saw a chart the other day
that was it was the Consumer Price Index
broken out by sector right and the you
know the price of TVs relatively
speaking is you know a fraction of what
it once was and the price of education
and healthcare are you know
astronomically higher than they wanted
to work and I think you know I always
clearly my greatest vice is confirmation
bias right when I see stuff that I agree
or everybody says I'm like maybe over
aware of that but right so so I like
looked at this chart and I was like can
I come up with a libertarian on
libertarian interpretation of this chart
like can I tell the story about why
these sectors went in opposite
directions that doesn't reinforce my
pre-existing libertarian beliefs and
then I was like nope I can't
like the sectors were government metals
most aggressively are the sectors that
haven't seen fantastical amazing but
let's talk about something that did see
fantastical amazing growth and then boom
plastic bags
you wrote a great cover story about
plastic bags for those who foolishly did
not read it or maybe have not remembered
it could you give us a little capsule
summary of why sure so it was basically
defense of the beleaguered plastic bag
and and the idea was was actually
sparked these are grocery bag groceries
so the little little film knee grocery
bags that you get that you you know that
used to be ubiquitous and now everybody
totes around the reusable bags and it's
all very wholesome and socially yes so
right here's my I got this at a trade
show actually but but it's for my
groceries so the the inspiration for the
article was actually some work by Julie
Morris at The Reason Foundation who had
kind of gathered together a bunch of
studies and he had published a very
super respectable white paper on this
question and I was like we should
probably sensationalize this and put it
on the cover reason values mean so the
argument is essentially that it's like
the plastic bag is a miracle of material
science it uses virtually nothing uses
like five Maalik
to carry two gallons of milk and you
know it's if you look at the math about
what actually consumes resources in what
ways it's not at all clear that these
reusable bags that everyone uses are on
net better on any of the tokens that
people argue so water pollution are like
pollution of our rivers and oceans water
use resource use global warming like you
can so the piece just ticks through all
of the arguments for why you should use
this like super trendy bag that says
this is not a plastic bag I got it
and I hope obliterates them all the the
piece of the article that I wanted to be
stronger that didn't work out in the end
was I really wanted there to be a study
that conclusively showed that plastic
plastic bags were protecting all of us
from e.coli and then we were all gonna
like die of horrible intestinal ailments
if we kept using these reusable bags and
like there is some evidence for that
claim but it is not as robust it's like
the argument that if we have compact
fluorescent bulbs we're all going to
talk you're gonna die poisoning which is
nonsense and if we were on the other
side we would see it as nonsense but
yeah because we don't like light bulb
bands a lot of people see previous
comments about exactly exactly so that's
the same the same kind of thing one of
the interesting things about your career
as distinct from mine or Nick's or
Matt's is that and you actually alluded
to this earlier is that you came up
through a coherent career path designed
to produce the editor of Reason magazine
essentially you yeah yeah you went first
of all we have something in common
very unusual as reason editors which is
that we both went to Ivy League schools
but you went to the one that produces
thing magazine editors or one of the two
whereas I went to the one that produces
Jeff Bezos now you're just bragging
but you know a bunch of a bunch of nurse
and a bunch of horrible also Eliot
Spitzer okay so there was that but then
you were you were an internet reason you
worked at the Weekly Standard you were
you work for John Tierney
whereas Nick worked you know interviewed
Alf over the telephone for a teen
magazine and I was a business journalist
and math started a paper in
Czechoslovakia we had these weird not
none of that infrastructure really
existed when we were coming up how if at
all does that change what sort of editor
you are and what does it say about the
the environment so I don't know if you
guys have seen that the first seven jobs
hashtag is going around right so this is
just people on Twitter on Facebook
sharing what their first seven jobs were
and I think it's fantastic like this is
it's such a great like I don't know
actually what the origin of it is but I
would like to think that it was
originated by people who are trying to
combat minimum wage laws because it's a
reminder that like everybody had these
weird dumb jobs that I was fired for the
minimum wage went from 232 to 65 so we
now know the exact value level employee
and the marginal worker but but like if
I was designing a campaign to oppose
minimum wage laws this is what I would
do I would get everyone in America to
remind themselves of their first seven
jobs but my entry would be horrible
because my first seven jobs like this is
my seventh job I mean I just you're
right like I like came up through you
know in a world where it was very easy
for me to get internships and have
school experiences and get subsidized by
a variety of benevolent donors to do all
the stuff that yeah I would like to
thank will make me a good reason editor
and fun fact actually when I was a
reason intern in the summer of 2000 in
Washington DC before we had a DC office
most of my summer was spent transcribing
the world's longest interview with this
obscure governor from New Mexico
about how he was like running marathons
or something and I was like who is this
guy but actually by the end of the
summer I was like this guy's going
somewhere and of course it's Gary
Johnson right and and it's there's a
sort of weird like circular nature I
think to like you know Here I am still
staring down the barrel of Gary Johnson
like puff pieces you know so many years
later but yeah I mean I actually think
you know in a lot of ways I probably you
know I probably suffer from not having
come up through various weird paths
because I I don't I I barely exist
outside this universe of like you know
think think magazines but I also love it
and I also like I think I'm pretty
knowledgeable about the field you know
that's that's the flip side of having no
other jobs is I spend a lot of time
reading the archives of all of these
magazines for instance
so what other magazines do you admire
not necessarily for the political
philosophy but for their journalism yeah
so I I was actually I was talking with
somebody about this earlier I was
reading the memo outlining what reason
enterprises would be like which was
written in what you're right so 1969 a
reason is barely in existence you're
Katherine is not Katherine is so long
from being in existence at that point
and it's you know it says well so the
goal is there's a bunch of goals and
then the kind of final goal is to
produce high quality magazine journalism
similar to Harper's and The New Yorker I
think it was the examples and like I
kind of I think it's like 50 years later
and we're still working on that but you
know I I read the Atlantic I loved the
Atlantic I read The New Yorker but I
actually like I said I don't read print
magazines how much I consume them online
I can tune them you know on a tablet I
can ask which websites do like you which
publications yeah and and I think you
know in in some ways the list really
hasn't changed
that much from what you might have said
decades ago but I also think that
reasons video division for instance was
very early in being super high quality
and that's a place where I think we do
kind of set a gold standard I mean
there's really there's really nobody
that's competing directly up against us
to do the kind of things that we do that
I think are as good as we are so there
are places where I would say we're
already at the top of the heap and
places where we still have some work to
do including the print magazine yeah so
you there was an interview with you
since you're the new editor a number of
people I'm interviewing and there was an
interview with you I actually don't
remember if it was because of your new
job or your old job but that was advice
for young aspiring intern journalists
types in DC and one of the things you
talked about and that was what you
called DC's DC's happy hour culture what
is DC's happy hour culture so this is
the thing that conspiracy theorists
imagine right like sometimes we get
these people who will say like oh you
just wrote that article because you want
to be invited to those DC cocktail
parties and so you have to be like nice
and palatable and not rock the boat and
the answer is like I do want to be
invited those DC cocktail parties I am
invited to those DC cocktail parties and
if anything I'm invited do to mine on
palatability right like there's a sort
of actually like this crazy
let's bring the crazy in but I and I was
actually just as a side note like being
a libertarian woman is like the best
path of tokenism that you can imagine
and like I'm sure I doctor tell you this
but I think I get the sweet spot of it
it was like the world was ready for a
few more of me but there the supply was
very limited so was like what goodbye
Catherine to all the things and now I
think it's like Darien ladies a time it
was it wasn't that interesting back in
the nineties either
yes kind of if you didn't write about
women's issues they weren't interested
in you but I think I think my advice to
two younger journalists was like go to
happy hours make friends if that's your
strength but a lot of writers are
introverts and a bit socially inept so
also know thyself so this is a bad year
I think for political for dynamism as I
would put it we have we have the two
major candidates running very strongly
against trade against immigration
against change in many ways against the
bottom-up change and and not only
running against it but particularly in
the Republican Party sort of purging it
from their coalition and the Democrats
is a little more confusing it's never
been a big part of their coalition but
they haven't actually purged
so we're there oh why shouldn't I be
super pessimistic about this what where
do we go from here I feel like this is
actually secretly a therapy session
they're just trying to get me to cheer
you up is that what's really I sit
around thinking about five hundred and
thousand year periods and you're like
above all this but it's not right so
this is this election cycle is horrific
and in fact like about once a week I
come in and I like you know open up
Twitter and and I'm like this is it I've
lost my capacity to be shocked by the
horror that is 2016 and then like my
Twitter feed squirrels a little bit and
I'm like you guys did you see this and
it's like once again I am full of rage
and and despair yes it's it's like the
two major party conventions were this
sort of hysterical display of status quo
thinking Trump versus Clinton versus
everything yeah and you know I do think
that the what now seems to be the sort
of universal opposition to the idea
that the movement of people and goods
across borders is a force for good is
going to have long-term negative
consequences like there's this story
cannot end well and you know whether you
sort of pinpoint the specific people
moving across our borders in which
direction and the specific goods in
which direction you know the the total
lack of that insight from our political
discourse is absolutely the thing that
scares me the most about 2016 right
now you it's interesting you use the
term status quo and there are many
things that many terms I might use to
describe Donald Trump but that is not
one of them and and in fact there's a
certain type of libertarian who kind of
likes the whole Trump phenomenon because
they're they want to burn everything
down
they they they it's not that they
necessarily like Donald Trump but they
just like his destructive power do you
see that do you see that element out
there or even on the staff I do see it
out in the world I I don't really see it
on reason staff I mean I am sympathetic
to I think the impulse behind some of
that Trump support which is nothing that
we're doing is even remotely working
let's try something else
and and I think for some people Trump is
the manifestation of that you know I
think people who are looking for
anti-war sentiment in Trump which is a
certain subset of libertarians are
missing the forest for the trees like he
may have said some words sometimes that
sounded a little bit like something that
might have been opposition to a war at
one point but I feel no reason to be
confident that I would he's not he's not
against fighting or starting wars he's
merely against losing them right he's
gonna be the best at war it's going to
be the best at Wars right so so I mean I
guess I would be wary of looking for
sort of any version of a libertarian
bright note on again provider birdie
right so one of the big tensions within
the libertarian movement is between what
I think of as Bob Poole style or Milton
Friedman style libertarian
incrementalism
you have a person who's like a diehard
libertarian but they really get down in
the weeds and they think about like how
can we move from A to B as opposed to
you know be mad that we're not at Z so
there's that and then there's the burn
it all down where we want to have
floating cities we want we anarchism is
the way to go that sort of libertarian
utopianism you might call it where do
you stand on that spectrum and how do
you see those tensions playing out in
the magazine so first of all that was
like the most stacked question I've ever
I know we have Milton Friedman and
reasons founder on the other side we
have people who just want the world to
burn which you know fair enough your
they know how that was the Trump people
want the world to burn no not the
anarchists they would hope so that air
whatever you told me you can spring up
they're all about how to get there
they're not necessarily destructive they
just it's a utopia you know we want
Milton Friedman what it was so I mean I
I am sympathetic to both sides and I
think that that it sounds like a wussy
answer but I actually I'm sporting my
reason orange today which wasn't fully
on purpose but probably was subconscious
messaging here I mean my libertarianism
is reason libertarianism which is not a
coherent body and so I kind of think
well let's make a magazine that always
has a floating city in it and also
always has like more hotly yeah I I
think Bob probably likes the flood
talked about it but I thought maybe on a
floating city right now for all we know
like has anybody seen them in a while
but you know I think there's no point in
the incremental ISM unless you're going
somewhere and it's you know I think a
big disease of American politics is that
people don't have somewhere they just
want to win
they want their team to win they want
red versus blue and I think you know the
animating principle of a lot of
incrementalism
can and should be you know let's
privatize the roads but you don't have
to say that every time at the end of
your argument right like it's to me it's
a it's a rhetorical stance to just say
if you and I can agree on legalizing pot
I don't need to say but also heroin and
vending machines for children at the end
of the conversation like I don't you
don't need to do that every time and not
doing that doesn't mean you're you
should be drummed out of the league
so the rap on libertarians in general
and reason in particular out there in
glib Twitter world or whatever is that
just people who all they care about is
drugs every question like yes that's all
we care about I mean you know I would
say drugs as part of drugs as part of
what we do a reason both it's literally
what we do a reason sometimes and also
it's a thing we advocate for legalizing
and you know it's probably too early to
say but you know I sort of Nick
Gillespie and and to some extent Matt
Welsh the their version of Reason was
sex drugs and rock and roll mine is more
like sex drugs and robots but it's still
drugs I think that's like it's just an
important make it different kind of
drugs to probably more like I want by
packing like yeah a pill that I can like
you know turn my eyeballs into computers
is more my jam but like everybody can do
their own thing I think it's a place
where we're actually winning and that's
the sort of super refreshing place
everybody make of solemn wrote something
about like whoa what world am I welcome
and that's suddenly I love them I mean
you know the libertarian moment has been
trotted out a lot by reason and by
others and it certainly doesn't feel
like a libertarian moment when you're
when you're looking at you know Donald
Trump's convention speech but you know
Scott Chuck bird who is he works here in
the LA office is an associate editor was
saying you know it's weird I actually
don't get a lot of traffic when I write
posts about incremental gains and you
know get
drug legalization initiatives on the
ballot you know people just don't really
click on these and it's because that's
old news
like it's super boring that Michigan
like it's probably not gonna legalize
weed this cycle cuz they're gonna do a
next cycle for bureaucratic reasons
that's great that's awesome
and and I don't see any reason why we
shouldn't be constantly reminding people
remember when you treated us like a
bunch of crazy idiots cuz we thought
this was a good idea welcome to the
party
alright so we have a question from
Joshua what are your goals for the site
slash magazine now we should clarify you
are only in charge of the print magazine
although you write for the site as well
do you intend to grow the readership of
slash membership and if so by how much
all the people in the whole world are
going to be reading reason by the time
I'm done so I mean it actually is an
interesting question because in general
print magazine subscriptions are not a
growing category and they haven't been a
growing category for decades and but the
vast majority of people who read the
stuff that we put in the magazine read
it online already
and so that audience is always part of
my audience as I'm putting together
stuff for the magazine I'm thinking also
how will this play online how will this
headline work online you know how can we
visually present it online and that
audience is growing hugely so and our
goal is absolutely to keep growing that
audience right now people our biggest
growth growth biggest growth area is
video and that's true across our our
sector it's a true across our industry
so we will give the people video does
reason to active subscription marketing
these days like direct mail one the kind
of stuff we used to spend a gazillion
dollars on and 90s or is it basically
maintaining and then subscriptions
coming in through the website we do a
lot less of that we used to that we used
to do in the 90s and again it's because
we have Union want to sell stuff people
want to buy and we have a whole bunch of
other stuff to sell so we a huge money
sink too we think what's our how do we
get more eyeballs on our content per
dollar that we spend and the answer is
mostly online you know I think one piece
of that is that you really do get a
different kind
of person right if you subscribe to
Reason magazine you your you're the
choir to some extent that's not
universally true but like mostly if
you're gonna say I want eleven issues of
Reason magazine every year you are
already sold on the some fundamental
point about libertarianism or it's a
hate read but frankly people mostly
don't subscribe for aries online it's a
really different picture a half of our
visitors come from social half of our
visitors are reading on mobile so these
are people who might you know this sort
of eternal hope that we might be
catching someone for the first time like
having that same experience that I had
when I was 15 and I read a copy of The
Fountainhead only it's like Scott
jacquard on drug legalization and
they're like wait a minute it all makes
sense now so but you do get the recent
commenters which I'm notorious
criticizing so our commenter is uh a
catch phrase among our commenters when
they don't like something as they say
this never would have happened when
Virginia was editor and some of these
characters were pretty sure were not
born when Virginia she's this kind of
like benevolent figure that hover I
don't know the side of it is also
Virginia has been known to talk a little
smack about our commenters in various
fora and so I would say they're they
both love and fear you and I can how
about you go for the same let's talk
about you yeah I mean I I am NOT I don't
like it mix it up in the comment section
but I have a weird appreciation for what
happens there I think it is like a
little community and we have a baby that
was born because somebody met their
partner in our comment section and that
baby's name is reason Sophia I'm sure
where you guys work is cool too but so
let's see one more question this week
Gary Johnson came out for a carbon tax
forced vaccination of smoking ban in
private restaurants how does the
libertarian support this guy remember
when I was talking about the orcas
so probably the other most famous
infamous covers
that I wrote for reason was the story
that I wrote in 2012 about why I don't
vote so I don't vote and one reason that
I don't vote is because it only
encourages the bastards as they say gary
johnson included I think he's I think
he's fantastic I think it's great that
he's doing as well as he is doing but
there are plenty of reasonable
objections to his positions I think
there are an awful lot more objections
to basically everyone else's positions
out there but yeah he's not like
libertarian Jesus Christ come down to
save us from our sins so so someone
wants to know will reason ever get
another Radley Balko is there another
Radley Balko this was like a unique
treasure and how about a second
amendment column oh those are good
questions
um so reason still has Radley Balko at
least in part I originally we have the
the original the golden oldie Radley
Balko of course we celebrate that he has
gone on to become a blogger for the
Washington Post but you will find him
for instance in our who is worse Trump
or Hillary featured in the last issue
but we really do continue to do the work
that he made his name doing at reason
it's shared among a bunch of staffers
but in some horrible way it's not hard
to do what he does because there are so
many stories to tell I mean Radley has a
real talent for finding incredible cases
and really doing justice to telling the
stories of people who have been wrongly
incarcerated who have been you know who
have overly harsh sentences who are just
sort of generally victims of an over
aggressive law enforcement bureaucracy
but you know there's no shortage of
those stories and we tell them every
single day and that's actually super
depressing sorry you guys and somebody
once asked what advice do you have for
aspiring journalist my number one piece
of advice is don't go to journalism
school you can learn everything you need
to know you know in an internship you
can learn it on the job
you should probably apply for an
internship at Reason magazine where we
actually pay so that's a unique and
special thing thanks to the Burton C
gray memorial internship funds and the
other piece of advice I have which is
advice I frequently give to young
journalists is if you're making ramen
noodles you should put an egg in there
because it makes them more delicious and
nutritious I'm gonna read this question
but then I'm gonna change it is this a
perfectly good question but I wanted
other than marijuana legalization and
LGBTQ rights what other areas of human
freedom economic or otherwise are you
optimistic about in the near future
so that's a good question and you know
you feel free to answer that question
but I would actually like to ask just
take the economic point of view okay are
there areas of economic freedom where
you're optimist yeah or it does
everything have to focus on these other
issues so I am going to shamelessly
plagiarize the insights of Marc Andreson
who is the probably the like most
prolific tweeter in my Twitter feed and
P America oh that's a lot late at night
which I love yeah so definitely follow
that guy this is he's a of course a
super famous venture capitalist and
internet entrepreneur and he says how
could you not be optimistic about a
world where every single person maybe
two billion additional people have
access to essentially the means of
production in the form of a smartphone
or an internet connection I am NOT super
optimistic about economic growth in the
United States narrowly in the very near
future
I am wildly insanely optimistic about
economic growth in many very very poor
countries because in the last couple of
decades a billion people went from
basically starving to not starving and
when you stop starving to death you
start being able to do incredible stuff
and
also the sort of listen to Donald Trump
they would go back to start right
because we don't want them to make sure
goods and sell them to us god forbid
I mean you know I think I think you know
a little bit more education and a little
bit less starving is is it sounds sort
of like overly simplistic but it's it's
probably the most powerful force for
economic growth that you could imagine
to say here's a way to access all the
information that humans have and here's
like maybe five minutes of leisure time
and like how can that not be a huge boom
how can they not be an incredible area
of growth so you know I think there are
plug there's political uncertainty and
political conditions that keep people
down and those will continue to exist
but I think there's a countervailing
force are there any Senate House or
gubernatorial races this fall that
reason will pay paying particular
attention to yeah forget the president I
am NOT the best person to answer that
question but I hope maybe Matt Matt
would be an excellent person that are
now our editor at large which I love
that title because it sounds like he's
on the lam like from me maybe like from
I don't know what but yes our editor at
large who is essentially right now
acting as a politics reporter and and
it's mostly covering the presidential
election but other levels I think that
people pay totally insufficient
attention to down ticket races and that
that is an irrational behavior of which
they should be ashamed and also one in
which I participate well thank you very
much thank you to our questioners